hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property investor but i used to be
an estate agent and in this video
i want to give you the five top things
that you need to know
about estate agents if you're a property
investor wanting to do deals with estate
agents now the really interesting thing
is this i speak to a lot of property
investors or people aspiring to be
property investors
and they're really scared to pick up the
phone and talk to estate agents
they find it intimidating they don't
know exactly what to say
and people say to me samuel i need a
script what do i say when i ring up on a
stage what do i say when i go into an
estate agent
shop how do i build rapport and get
relationships and
i really think you just need to
understand
where they're coming from because the
biggest thing about communication and
about building relationships
is to put yourself in the shoes and
understand where the other person's
coming from so as
an ex-estate agent this is where estate
agents are coming from
and these are the five things that you
need to know and the first thing is
estate agents are just
people they're human beings and usually
they're people who are actually quite
young and
it's easy to think they're experts in
property and i'm scared to speak to them
in case i say something wrong in case i
look stupid in case
you know but actually an estate agent is
just a human being
they probably don't know that much about
property themselves
they're just in a job where they happen
to be selling property so that's the
first thing so just
relax people people think um in terms of
b2b
business to business or b2c i always
think whenever i'm doing business it's
just
h2h human to human so that's the first
thing second thing is
the estate agents are sales people
so this is the thing that freaks me out
is when people investors
almost feel like they're disturbing an
estate agent by phoning them up and
saying i want to buy a house
the estate agent wants to sell houses
that's their job
they need to sell houses so it's not
like you're knocking on a cold person's
door
and saying hey is your house for sale
and they're going to be like oh
go away stop disturbing me estate agents
are
waiting for the phone to ring and their
job
is to sell houses so if you ring them up
and you say
hey i'm an investor looking to buy a
house they're going to be really
happy to hear from you believe me so you
really
don't need to fear about phoning estate
agents the third thing about estate
agents and by the way most of these
things
are all going to make you feel confident
to ring estate agents because my job
as a property youtuber my mission is to
make people financially free in property
and to become financially free in
property you need to actually find
deals and to find deals you need to
build a relationship with your state
agent so all these five things should
give you confidence but if you're
enjoying the video so far
smash a like also drop a comment let me
know what you like best about the video
of course subscribe and turn the
notification bell on
for the rest of the video the blue thumb
needs to be pointing up okay i hope the
blue thumb is pointing up and it's blue
not white
so the third thing is this estate agents
they are
communicators and their job is to when
you phone them up is to
ask you questions so in terms of a
script
and this is a big problem that people
have when they phone us their agents
they'll phone estate agent up
and they'll think they need to prepare
this speech
you know they're gonna get this script
and they're to go
my name is john and i'm an investor and
here's my life story and this is what
i'm looking to do this is what i'm
looking for
but actually it's really easy because
when you follow an estate agent what
you'll find is
very quickly they will lead the
conversation and they'll say
what kind of things are you looking for
you know are you an investor are you
looking to buy yourself
what areas what price and they'll start
asking you questions and all you need to
do
is just answer the questions that
they're asking you and just be honest
and upfront with where you're at
and if you if if you're literally just
phoning up because you're just a bit
curious
and you're not an investor but you
aspire to be and you just want to see
what the market's doing
then just say that and you'll find that
estate agents
they'll ask you questions they'll lead
the conversation they'd tend to be nice
people
and then definitely definitely not scary
so that's the third thing
fourth thing is it's it's really
important to bear in mind that estate
agents
are on a point system now what i mean by
that is
they get rewarded for of course how many
houses that they sell
which is awesome but they also get
rewarded for other things as well
like how many viewings they book and
this isn't necessarily the case for
every single estate agent but i used to
work for countrywide which is one of the
largest estate agents in the country
and most estate agents do work like this
that means that at the end of every
single day
they're going to be asked how many
viewings have you booked today
and they're gonna have to give an answer
now the higher number of viewings
they've booked
the more brownie points they're gonna
get from their manager or their boss
so when you ring up on book reviewing or
ask to book a viewing again
this is like music to the estate agent's
ears so don't
feel like you're putting them out or oh
is it possible no
they want to book a viewing they'll also
try and do things like they'll try and
book you in to see their mortgage
advisor
and you might think why are they trying
to book me in to see their mortgage
advisor and the reason is
because they're on points every time
they book you to go and see the mortgage
advisor
that's called an fma a first mortgage
appointment and i used to get asked
every single day
how many viewings have you booked how
many fmas have you booked
how many and and their jobs their own
point is to just book as many viewings
as many appointments as possible so if
an estate agent
when you ring them if they if if they're
like oh i'm not really that interested
and they're not bothered about you and
they're not
trying to help you and trying to assist
you then don't take it personally
they're just not doing their job
properly because they are on a point
system so
i think this might help you when you
speak to them because you understand the
mindset of the estate agent
the fifth thing i want to say about
state agents this is so important is
estate agents are your best
friend now this is so important because
people think
that amateur investors buy from estate
agents but then when you become
professional
then you don't you know you don't want
on market deals you want to find
properties
off market and you want you want to go
direct to vendor
and advertise when you're professional
but the truth is when you become
seasoned you realize that the best deals
actually do come from a staged agents
and just because it's with an estate
agent doesn't mean that it's it's on the
market because
when you have a a relationship with an
estate agent
what will happen is they'll pass deals
to you before it even goes on the market
which means that
they'll they'll get a call from somebody
and a really motivated seller also i
need to sell my house really really
quickly
and the estate agent before they even
put it on the market will think hmm
i know who might be interested in that
samuel leeds or whoever
and then they'll ring you direct so i i
do get
very very good property deals from
estate agents and i think that a good
relationship with an estate agent
is far far better than a good deal
because when you've got a good
relationship
you're going to get a deal after deal
after deal after deal so
the purpose of this video was to give
you a little bit of confidence
in picking up the phone and speaking to
estate agents and listen
even if you haven't got loads of money
and you're not a bit unconfident my
suggestion would be
to go into an estate agent's office and
just tell them that you're really
interested in property
you're looking to buy your first
investment and and just have a
conversation
what's the worst that can happen they're
just people
their job is to sell property deals and
if you want to buy property deals even
if you can't do it right yet
start building those relationships so my
challenge to you
is to pick up the phone tomorrow book of
viewing
talk to an estate agent and hey if you
end up getting a deal
don't forget to come back to my youtube
channel and let me know how it went
if you want to learn more about how to
get negotiate great deals and the magic
words that you need to use
check out this video right here and if
you also if you want to see a whole
playlist
of people that i have helped become
financially free in property there's
plenty of stories right here
and don't forget to subscribe to my
youtube channel over here so you never
miss
a future video with top tips to help you
in property